you've been keeping up with all this
view drama not enough to make a comment
about it here oh i feel you on that
don't worry we're gonna catch you up
right now let's start with tonight's hot
topic whoopee suspension
the holocaust isn't about race
you all saw the news the view co-host
whoopi goldberg suspended for two weeks
whoopi will be back here in two weeks
joy behar stepped in as moderator today
giving whoopee suspension just a seven
second mention before moving on e.t has
obtained this letter sent last night to
staffers from the president of abc news
announcing the suspension and revealing
that whoopi was asked to take time to
reflect and learn about the impact of
her comments
after making the false holocaust
statement whoopi spent the next 24 hours
in damage control mode but seemed to
double down on colbert i don't want to
fake apologize this wasn't based on the
skin you couldn't tell who was jewish
they had to delve deeply to figure it
out
i regret my comments as i said and i
stand corrected i also stand with the
jewish people as they know and y'all
know because i've always done that it is
indeed about race because hitler and the
nazis considered jews to be an inferior
race former co-host megan mccain called
whoopi's comments deeply offensive
adding quote whoopi has said a slew of
insanely controversial things over the
course of her tenure at the view she's
the queen of the castle there this
morning on her podcast former view host
michelle collins speculated whoopi was
okay with the suspension part of me
wonders if she sort of sacrificed
herself if she maybe felt like this is
what's gonna take the heat off the show
are you ready to get back in the studio
no
we talked to whoopi twice last year at
home and back in the studio where she
was grateful for her job at the view not
everybody gets to have an opinion not
everybody gets to say this is what i
think and here's why this is a really
great job